♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO ON MARCH 25TH THE RESEARCHER
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
MASSACHUSETTS CONDUCTED AN
INTERESTING SURVEY.
HE REACHED OUT TO THE
EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS AND ASKED, HOW MANY
AMERICANS WILL DIE FROM THIS
OUTBREAK OF THE CORONAVIRUS?
THE AVERAGE ESTIMATE HE GOT BACK
WAS 245,000 PEOPLE.
THAT’S IT SO HAPPENED THAT
ALMOST MATCHED EXACTLY THE
PRODUCTION FROM THE INSTITUTE OF
MEDICINE WASHINGTON.
AS RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY YOU
HEARD SOME AUTHORITIES SITE
THOUGH SOME NUMBERS EFFECTIVELY
IN PUBLIC, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
WILL DIE.
THIS MORNING THE IH MEE ISSUED
NEW NUMBERS.
THEY NOW PREDICT 60,000 DEATHS
IN THIS COUNTRY BY AUGUST 4TH
WHICH IS ONE QUARTER OF THE
ORIGINAL PROJECTION.
NUMBERS FOR INDIVIDUAL STATES
HAVE CHANGED AS WELL.
IN VIRGINIA FOR EXAMPLE WHICH IS
CURRENTLY SUFFERING UNDER A
LOCKDOWN UNTIL JUNE THE MODEL
NOW PREDICTS A TOTAL OF 891
DEATHS STATEWIDE.
JUST A WEEK AGO THE IH MEE
ADDICTED 3,073 DEATHS WHICH IS
MORE THAN THREE TIMES WHAT THEY
ARE NOW SAYING.
AT THIS POINT WE SHOULD NOT
SURPRISE THE MODEL GOT IT WRONG.
THE PREDICTION OF HOW MANY
HOSPITAL BEDS WE’D NEED TURNED
OUT TO BE COMPLETELY
DISCONNECTED FROM REALITY AND
THAT MATTERS QUITE A BIT BECAUSE
THOSE NUMBERS WERE THE MAIN
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE LOCKDOWN.
REMEMBER OUR EFFORTS TO FLATTEN
THE CURVE?
THEY WEREN’T CRAZY, THERE WAS A
GOOD REASON FOR DOING THAT.
WE DIDN’T WANT OUR HEALTH SYSTEM
TO COLLAPSE UNDER A FLOOD OF NEW
CORONAVIRUS PATIENTS.
SO FAR IT HAS NOT COLLAPSED BUT
NOT BECAUSE WE PREPARED
EFFECTIVELY, WE DIDN’T REALLY.
THERE WERE JUST FAR FEWER PEOPLE
THAT NEEDED INPATIENT MEDICAL
TREATMENT.
THE MODEL PREDICTED THAT ON
APRIL 4TH NEW YORK WOULD NEED
65,000 HOSPITAL BEDS AND THE
ACTUAL NUMBER WAS 16,000.
YOU ARE HEARING PEOPLE NOW SAY
THAT THE SPREAD BETWEEN
PREDICTION AND REALITY MUST BE
DUE TWO SOCIAL DISTANCING BUT
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
SOCIAL DISTANCING MEASURES WERE
FACTORED INTO THE MODEL FROM THE
BEGINNING.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE FOUR TIMES
LARGER BUT SOMETHING ELSE SKEWED
THE NUMBERS.
AT THE SAME TIME THE IH AND E
HAS BEEN MORE ACCURATE ON DEAF
TOTALS.
IN SOME CASES THEY HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY OVERSTATED THE
KNOT BY 400%.
THE IH AND WE ANNOUNCE AT 65,000
PEOPLE AMERICANS WILL DIE BY THE
TIME THE VIRUS ENDS.
FOR PERSPECTIVE WE WILL READ YOU
KNOW A SERIES OF NUMBERS.
SOME PEOPLE MAY BE OFFENDED TO
HEAR THIS BUT THERE’S NO REASON
TO BE.
ACCURATE STATISTICS ARE NOT
OFFENSIVE.
THEY ARE PART OF REALITY AND
REALITY SHOULD ALWAYS BE THE
BASELINE FROM WHICH WE MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS EVEN IF WE
OURSELVES HAVE MADE OTHER
PREDICTIONS IN THE PAST, EVEN IF
WE ARE EMBARRASSED TO ADMIT WHAT
WE NOW KNOW.
WE SHOULD DO IT ANYWAY BECAUSE
EGO DOESN’T MATTER AT A TIME
LIKE THIS.
THE TRUTH MATTERS.
SO HERE ARE A FEW NUMBERS.
AN ESTIMATED 60,000 AMERICANS
WILL DIE FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC IN 2018,
61,000 AMERICANS DIED OF THE
ANNUAL FLU.
THAT SAME YEAR MORE THAN 67,000
DIED FROM DRUG OVERDOSES.
NEARLY 50,000 DIED FROM SUICIDE.
ABOUT 88,000 AMERICANS DIED FROM
ALCOHOL ABUSE.
83,000 DIED FROM DIABETES.
MORE THAN 606,000 DIED FROM
CANCER.
IT COULD GO ON.
BUT FOR NOW LET’S LOOK AT TWO OF
THOSE NUMBERS, OVERDOSES AND
SUICIDES, BOTH BY THE WAY
DISPROPORTIONATELY KILL YOUNG
PEOPLE.
LET’S SAY THE DEATH PROJECTIONS
WERE TOO LOW FOR THE SAKE OF
ARGUMENT IN THIS WOULD BE THE
FIRST TIME THAT HAPPENED.
BUT AGAIN JUST FOR THE SAKE OF
THE EXERCISE, LET’S ASSUME THE
REAL NUMBER IS TWICE AS BAIT.
IT’S 120,000, THAT’S HOW MANY
AMERICANS WILL DIE IN THE
OUTBREAK.
IF THAT’S TRUE THAT WOULD STILL
BE AROUND AS MANY PEOPLE THAT
HAVE DIED FROM OVERDOSES AND
SUICIDES.
BOTH OF WHICH OUR LEADERS
ESSENTIALLY IGNORE.
DEATHS LIKE THOSE ARE NOT
CONSIDERED A GOVERNMENT PROBLEM.
THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS,
PROTECTING OURSELVES AGAINST THE
WUHAN CORONAVIRUS, WHICH IS
DANGEROUS AND SCARY, WE THROWN
AN ESTIMATED 17 MILLION PEOPLE
OUT OF WORK.
WE’VE SPENT MORE THAN
$2 TRILLION IN BORROWED MONEY
AND THAT’S JUST THE RESPONSE SO
FAR.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TELL YOU
THAT WHAT OUR LEADERS HAVE DONE
IN THE LAST MONTH AS
DISPROPORTIONATE, YOU CAN DECIDE
THAT FOR YOURSELF BUT IT’S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT GOING FORWARD BECAUSE
AGAIN, REALITY MATTERS.
EVEN IF IT EMBARRASSES US TO
ADMIT IT.
MANY POLITICIANS WHO DON’T SEEM
TO BE THINKING ABOUT IT.
IN THE FACE OF IMPROVING
NUMBERS, NEW JERSEY
GOVERNOR PHIL MURPHY ANNOUNCED
HIS STATE WOULD "IF ANYTHING
TITAN AS OPPOSED TO LOOSEN
LOCKDOWN RESTRICTIONS."
STATEMENTS LIKE THAT MAKE YOU
WONDER WHAT’S REALLY GOING ON.
HIS PUBLIC HEALTH THE ONLY
CONSIDERATION FOR THESE PEOPLE?
MAYBE NOT.
HERE IS A ZQ MANUAL HAS NOT ONLY
AN ACADEMIC BUT ALSO A LONGTIME
POLITICAL HACK EXPLAINING ON
MSNBC THIS MORNING THAT AMERICA
MUST REMAIN IN ITS CURRENT STATE
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF.
NOW KEEP IN MIND, ALMOST THE
VERY MOMENT THAT ZQ MANUAL SAID
THIS, THE IH ME WAS REVISING ITS
TOTAL DEATH RATE DOWN TO
60,000.
>> I DO THINK WE WILL RETURN TO
WHAT WE THINK IS NORMAL, THE
SORT OF PRECOVID-19 SITUATION
ONLY WITH A VACCINE OR SOME VERY
EFFECTIVE PREVENTATIVE THAT
EVERYONE CAN TAKE.
THAT IS 18 MONTHS AWAY AND WE
NEED TO KEEP VERY, VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THAT.
WE ARE NOT GETTING THAT AROUND
THE CORNER.
>> Tucker: YOU WANT TO GIVE
EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT IN THE
MIDDLE OF A CRISIS BUT HONESTLY,
YOU HAVE TO WONDER WHAT
MOTIVATES PEOPLE TO SAY THINGS
LIKE WHAT YOU JUST HEARD?
IF YOU ARE SINCERELY TRYING TO
HELP THE COUNTRY WOULD BE
FOCUSED ON EFFECTIVE MEDICAL
TREATMENTS FOR THIS DISEASE.
A DRUG THAT SAVED EVEN HALF OF
PATIENTS HEADING TOWARDS DEATH
WITH CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE
IMMEDIATELY AND FOREVER.
IN A SITUATION LIKE THIS,
SCIENCE IS OUR HOPE.
SO YOU THINK OUR MEDIA WOULD BE
FOLLOWING EVERY MEDICAL ADVANCE
AT LEAST AS CLOSELY AS WE FOLLOW
THE FINAL FOUR.
BUT NO, THEY ARE DOING JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
THEY ARE IGNORING PROMISING
TREATMENTS IN FAVOR OF PROMOTING
EVER MORE IMPRESSIVE SOCIAL
CONTROLS.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THAT?
IN THE CASE OF THE DRUG
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WHICH DOCTORS
ARE GIVING RIGHT NOW TO
THOUSANDS OF CORONAVIRUS
PATIENTS, REPORTERS WHO HAVE NO
GROUNDING IN SCIENCE ARE TELLING
US THAT IT’S UNPROVEN AND RISKY
APPARENTLY IN CONTRAST TO
EVERYTHING ELSE WE ARE DOING.
>> DR. FAUCI IS SAYING THOSE
STUDIES ARE NOT SCIENTIFIC AND
CHLOROQUINE ALSO CARRIES
CARDIOVASCULAR RISKS.
FOR THE CONTINUES TO ENDORSE
DRUG.
>> WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOOSE?
>> WILL POTENTIALLY YOU COULD
LOSE YOUR LIFE.
>> EXPERTS SAY THERE ISN’T
ENOUGH CLINICAL DATA TO SHOW
IT’S EFFECTIVE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS AND THERE ARE SOME
SERIOUS SIDE EFFECTS.
>> YOU CONTINUE TODAY TO PUSH
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IN A WAY THAT
IS BAFFLING TO MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS.
>> GENE ROBINSON, WROTE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THE ONE
WORD THAT PROVES WHY
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD NOT BE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT IS IT?
>> HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT AND THEY DON’T CARE TO
LEARN.
YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY’RE
DOING, THEY ARE LAUNCHING
PARTISAN POLITICAL ATTACKS AND
PRETEND AGAINST MEDICAL ADVICE.
THAT’S ALWAYS WRONG.
RIGHT NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF A